[Music]
you've
spoken a bit about and i've read some
articles about you're experiencing
having
your experience having an eating
disorder so
what did that stem from how did you
manage to get that under control
what was that like that stemmed from my
mom
another surprise mommy she's back
um when i was 11 i i played a lot of
roles on tv that were like for younger
act like i played
seven or eight because i was very small
one day i felt
like a lump in my breast and i was very
scared i thought like oh my god my mom
had cancer now i have cancer i'm only 11
how can i have cancer
and i go to my mom i'm like terrified
and she goes oh no you're
you don't have cancer you're just
developing breasts the only thing that
would have been worse for me at that
time than like hearing that i had cancer
was hearing that i was gonna have
breasts because growing up
meant that i would not be able to pay my
family's bills i didn't my mom was
always very
vocal about like it's good when you play
younger roles i don't
who knows what your career will be like
once you can't play these younger roles
like we need to get you
we need to get you on a hot stream that
kind of talk yeah
um so i thought okay i said okay well
what can i do to
to not have boobs and my mom said well
there's this thing called calorie
restriction which is anorexia
it really felt to me like we were in a
buddy comedy
like doing the hand jives and then like
eating 400 calories a day
like it it felt like the happy montage
in a movie only it was this very sick
and disturbing
situation that i wasn't aware of because
i was a child i wasn't aware that my mom
was
teaching me anorexia you know she gave
me stacks of diet books she weighed me
she measured my thighs with the
measuring tape to make sure that they
weren't
yikes previous weeks like very intense
stuff
um and i just thought this was normal
and when she would tell me not to tell
my friends i thought it's because we
have such a special relationship
it's not it's not because she's doing
anything bad it's because like yeah
other
girls wouldn't get it because their
relations with their moms are just like
weak weird golden um
so that was where that started and and
then uh and i mean i've been through all
the eating disorders so anorexia for me
was 11 to
15. then my eating kind of like
normalized i don't really have a
reason for why um i was on a show at
that time so maybe it was just like
knowing that i had kind of reached the
goal there was no longer a
career goal in my
mind and then um by 16
i got my period i was very late to get
my period and then i went
back to anorexia because i was so
terrified of growing up again
and then um by 18 when my mom was
diagnosed with cancer i had binge eating
disorder
by 21 the year that she died i had
anorexia and then bulimia for three
years
and that is the end of that like that
was the end of my uh my eating disorder
history
that sounds unpleasant in a word
yeah totally okay so how are you doing
now and did you get it under control and
how did you manage that
it's another thing that i tribute to to
dbt that type of therapy that i
mentioned earlier um
i mean i really think that that specific
type of therapy changed my life
i've never heard of that yeah it's i
mean i think
cbt has definitely talked about
cognitive girl and it's like talk
therapy is amazing and i think really
like for me now that's kind of that's
that's the game
that but but dbt was really needed for
like the extent of the issues
that i had i just don't think they could
have been resolved by anything less and
i needed to be a part of the program as
you also have coach calls which is where
you're able to call your therapist
any hour of the day or night when you're
dealing with your issues most
for something like bulimia when that's a
behavior that you need to really
be on top of like the amount of time
that i was calling my therapist to be
like
i want to throw up i want i mean it's
crazy it's it's
it's impossible to achieve that level of
contact with the therapist in any other
type of
[Music]
therapy